bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour une nouvelle émission
d'europe hebdo et dans cette émission
peggy da la colère qui secoue
l'allemagne depuis trois mois le pays
voit grossir avec inquiétude le
mouvement anti-islam encore très
minoritaires ils commencent toutefois à
faire des émules en autriche espagne
belgique et france
on ira à dresde en allemagne avec
jérémie hoffmann au coeur de ce
mouvement
mais avant revenons à l'actualité après
les attentats à paris l'opération
antiterroriste en belgique l'europe se
mobilise
une première réunion des ministres des
affaires étrangères des 28 a eu lieu il
ya quelques jours à bruxelles
l'idée c'est de renforcer la
collaboration dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
ils se sont retrouvés pour accorder
leurs violons sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'union européenne veulent désormais
agir
les enjeux sont européens tous les pays
sont menacés on le voit aujourd'hui avec
la belgique
mais les moyens eux sont nationaux par
exemple l'europe n'a pas de service de
renseignement pour l'instant les
informations sont transmises de capital
la capitale au bon vouloir de chacun
malgré tout les ministres européens des
affaires étrangères planche sur trois
pistes la création d'un fichier européen
des passagers aériens
il permettrait de repérer des personnes
qui se rendent par exemple en syrie
ensuite un renforcement des contrôles
aux frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne aujourd'hui les douanes se
contentent bien seulement de vérifier
que votre passeport n'a pas été volé
enfin la mise sur pied d'un programme
européen de lutte contre la
radicalisation
cela peut être sur internet ou bien sûr
dans les prisons si la première réunion
avant un sommet des chefs d'état des 28
à la mi février qui sera consacré au
terrorisme
avec une certitude chez de nombreux
responsables européens
le terrorisme est un mal qui peut
toucher tous les pays d'europe
il est désormais nécessaire que tous
s'unissent et échangent leurs
informations
aucun pays n'est à l'abri
voilà la somme avec arnaud danjean
bonjour vous êtes député européen du pp
1 qui regroupe les partis de droite et
du centre-droit membre de la commission
des affaires étrangères et spécialiste
des questions de défense à leurs
questions toutes simples
au moment où je vous parle est ce que
les citoyens européens se sont bien
protégés globalement ils le sont et
évidemment la tragédie de paris occulte
un peu tout ce qui se passe par ailleurs
en termes de prévention du terrorisme et
de neutralisation d'un certain nombre de
réseaux mais on peut considérer quand
même que les polices européennes et les
services de renseignement européens sont
globalement efficace donc la protection
est à un niveau élevé
évidemment mais ça c'est valable sur la
durée il n'y a aucun mécanisme
infaillible que ce soit des mécanismes
législatifs
on pourra renforcer autant qu'on veut
les législations on pourra améliorer
autant qu'on veut nos outils de
renseignement et de police il ya aucun
mécanisme infaillible en matière de
lutte antidrogue c'est l'espace schengen
la circulation des biens donc des arts
des personnes des arbres aussi est-ce
que c'est pas une faille on ne je pense
qu'il est tout à fait possible
il est tout à fait possible de combiner
liberté de circulation et protection je
pense aussi que la solution qui consiste
à dire il faut mettre à bas schengen il
faut démanteler schengen
ça ne garantit pas une protection contre
terrorisme regardez la grande bretagne
elle n'est pas membre de schengen
elle a été touchée à plusieurs reprises
et notamment en 2005 par des attentats
qui ont été parmi les plus
spectaculaires en europe donc c'est pas
ça le problème le problème c'est que ces
combinés la liberté de circulation de
schengen avec un contrôle plus
systématique plus approfondie aux
frontières et l'alimentation des
fichiers schengen parce qu on oublie
souvent qu'à côté de la liberté de
circulation qui est un principe schengen
ce sont aussi des mécanismes et
notamment des mécanismes de contrôle qui
ne sont pas toujours utilisées à plein
j'allais dire par par les états membres
pourtant l'europe a là des outils pour
se protéger contre le terrorisme par
exemple le programme pnr de de son nom
de code c'est à dire un registre commun
des passagers aériens qui circulent en
europe
est ce que cette cette mesure elle
pourra s'appliquer demain ou alors c'est
pour la saint glinglin qu'est ce qu'on
attend pour voter le texte
eh ben on attend que certains collègues
du parlement européen d'autres groupes
parce que le ppe à tous
soutenu le pnr européens l'adoption de
ce pnr européen on attend que les autres
groupes se décide à franchir le pas et
cessent de considérer qu'un pnr serait
liberticide ou sera une intrusion
insupportable dans les libertés civiques
des européens le pmr doit bien sûr être
encadrés par un certain nombre de
garde-fous juridique on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi
il s'agit pas de mettre en place un
programme de surveillance massif à
l'américaine il s'agit simplement
d'utiliser un outil dont tous les
services de police et de renseignement
nous disent qu'ils seraient
particulièrement utiles pour la
traçabilité des personnes suspectes
on ne peut plus s'en passer aujourd'hui
c'est pas la panacée ça sera pas la
baguette magique mais en même temps
c'est un vrai instrument qui apportent
une valeur ajoutée alors on l'a dit les
ministres européens des affaires
étrangères se sont réunis cette semaine
pour mettre au point la réponse
européenne au terrorisme alors chacun y
allait de sa solution on écoute ce que
demande le ministre néerlandais des
affaires étrangères on l'écouté on
réagit juste après
nous insistons particulièrement sur le
fait que nous devons tarir les
ressources de financement pour des
groupes comme l'organisation état
islamique afin de s'assurer que les
relations entre les groupes ici et là
bas sont nous voulons une bonne
coopération dans la branche de
l'intelligence est aussi ce qui est très
important et de commencer à résoudre les
problèmes là-bas en syrie et en irak
voilà pour les solutions du ministre
néerlandais des affaires étrangères
arnaud danjean mettre sur pied une
agence européenne de renseignement est
ce que c est possible ou c'est
irréalisable est ce que ça fait surtout
pardonnez moi l'expression un peu brutal
mais c'est typiquement la fausse bonne
idée
pourquoi pourquoi ce que le
renseignement c'est opérationnel surtout
leur enseignement en lutte
antiterroriste et de l'infiltration de
réseau c'est du recueil du renseignement
sensible c'est la détection de sources
qui peuvent renseigner sur des groupes
terroristes extrêmement dangereux c'est
pas une agence européenne qui va régler
la question c'est pape avant de
mutualiser leurs enseignements il faut
l'acquérir et l'acquisition du
renseignement il se fait très bien c'est
sûr les états se fait très bien par les
services de renseignements nationaux on
a déjà pléthore de services de
renseignement nationaux services
intérieurs services extérieurs à peu
près dans tous les pays de l'union
européenne
donc c'est pas ça le problème le
problème que les informations
s'échangent des leviers à l'autre les
informations circulent très très bien
entre services de renseignement il n'y a
pas de rétention d'informations
ça fait très longtemps que ça circule
bien il ya des instances informel qui se
passe très bien
donc le problème n'est pas celui de la
coordination européenne et
internationale
on peut l'améliorer bien sûr on peut
avoir des fichiers communs plus
systématique et ça peut être le rôle par
exemple qui est dévolue à europol mais
pour autant
europol peut centraliser des données
mais c'est pas europol qui va aller les
chercher ces données et ceux qui vont
chercher ces données sur le terrain ce
sont les agences de renseignement
national et elles font bien leur boulot
elle coopère bien c'est pas ça vraiment
le problème je crois que encore une fois
il n'ya pas de dispositif infaillible il
ya quelques pistes on a parlé du pnr on
a parlé du renforcement des contrôles
schengen aux frontières extérieures
pourra qu'augmenter la la traçabilité
des personnes à risque j'entendais le
ministère avait parlé de tarir les
sources de financement
c'est déjà largement fait vous savez les
ce type de sanctions des gels d'avoirs
ou ce genre de choses c'est quelque
chose qui après le 11 septembre 2001
avait déjà été largement mis en oeuvre
sous l'égide d'ailleurs de résolutions
onusiennes au niveau de l'union
européenne je pense qu'il faut aussi
travailler à l'harmonisation des
législations parce que vous n'êtes pas
considérée comme terroriste et donc les
fichiers ne sont pas alimentés de la
même façon au niveau européen selon que
vous êtes en france en espagne en italie
au royaume uni ou autres pourquoi parce
que les codes pénaux n'incrimine pas de
la même façon les actions terroristes
en france on incrimine de façon souvent
est tant mieux
préventive j'allais dire avec une loi
qui permet de dire entreprise terroriste
en lien avec pardon entreprise
criminelle association de malfaiteurs en
lien avec une entreprise terroriste
c'est une définition qui permet de faire
beaucoup de choses ça n'existe pas dans
tous les pays parfois dans certains pays
tant qu'il ya pas eu de passage à l'acte
vous ne pouvez pas être incriminé dans
une entreprise terroriste ce qui fait
que votre nom n'est pas inscrit dans des
dans des fichiers ou des choses comme ça
donc on peut harmoniser les législations
c'est pas une dire c'est pas une
compétence de l'union européenne en tant
que telle mais j'allais dire une
incitation à l'harmonisation des
législations est importante
permettez moi juste un petit mot
j'entendais dire que la réunion qui
s'est déroulée cette semaine des 28
ministres c'est une réunion qui était
prévue de longue date c'est une réunion
régulière
elle a parlé du terrorisme comme
d'autres sujets les vrais rayons des
livres mettra sur une réunion le 12 de
leur lait cherrier chef d'état mais la
réunion les réunions décisives en
matière de d'antiterrorisme c'est plutôt
les réunions des ministres de
l'intérieur ce qu'on appelle le conseil
justice et affaires intérieures
je voulais avoir le point de vue du dpe
député européen sur cette radicalisation
des de ces jeunes comment vous
l'expliquez en europe on peut c'est un
phénomène sociologique extrêmement lourd
donc il ya beaucoup d'études qui sont
faites écouter on considère quand même
qu'il ya des zones d'attraction
effectivement là en ce moment c'est
syrie irak avec un côté spectaculaire au
conflit qui nous entourent qui font
beaucoup de publicité à ce genre de
choses évidemment chose qui n'existait
pas avant
le visage massif des réseaux sociaux et
de l'internet ça c'est vrai que
l'ouverture provoquée par les réseaux de
communication touche des publics qui
n'était pas touché auparavant
et puis il ya des malaises peut-être
plus spécifiques à chacun de nos pays
qui explique que en particulier dans
notre pays en france bon il ya sans
doute des raisons sociologiques et
culturelles très profondes en matière
d'intégration en particulier qui
explique aujourd'hui qu'un certain
nombre de jeunes basculent dans une
radicalisation qu'on n'avait pas
forcément vu venir
merci en tout cas arnaud danjean d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et maintenant
place aux reportages ça se passe en
europe le mouvement islamophobe mais
guida commence à faire peur il est né à
dresde dans l'ex allemagne de l'est qui
sont ces personnes qui manifestent
contre les musulmans des paumés
sur regardez le reportage de jérémy
hartmann
ambiance glaçante dans la fraîcheur des
rues de dresde
comme chaque lundi soir les manifestants
de peggy là des files fièrement sous les
huées des contre manifestants anti paix
guida les policiers sont sur le qui vive
pendant plusieurs heures
la ville va vivre coupé en deux les
guida se sont littéralement les
patriotes européens contre
l'islamisation de l'occident ces gens
qui partent en syrie ou en irak qu'ils y
restent et qu'ils ne reviennent pas chez
nous dans ces deux pays les soutiennent
beaucoup et nous on a besoin d'être
mieux protégé des nationalistes d'un
nouveau genre méprisant médias et
pouvoir politique le mouvement inquiète
tous ceux qui refusent que l'allemagne
répète les erreurs du passé
en signe de désapprobation l'éclairage
de certains bâtiments a été éteint comme
les églises de la ville
l'obscurité contre l'obscurantisme à
l'école des beaux-arts des étudiantes
ont même pas aux fenêtres des appels à
la tolérance
c'est important d'être là en tant
qu'école des beaux-arts on est dans une
ville culturelle sur les berges de
l'elbe et c'est très touristique
c'est pour cela qu'on a affiché ce
message is more
une réaction en forme de sursaut
démocratique qui agace les manifestants
de peggy da da ce lien nous vous savez
nous sommes qui est pour l'allemagne et
du coup nous sommes automatiquement
associée aux nazis et ça ce n'est pas
possible
nascar nissan caricaturer tous les
manifestants de peggy dahan fasciste
d'extrême droite serait une erreur
d'appréciation
à en croire ce professeur d'économie de
l'université de dresde sirat c'est tout
d'abord le groupe qui s'est formé
s'attaquer à l'islam radical ensuite il
y a eu de plus en plus de gens qui sont
venus manifester plus seulement contre
l'islamisme mais contre l'islam les
musulmans en général les étrangers etc
guida a laissé faire ça les arrange bien
de ne pas avoir de mots d'ordre précis
18000 la semaine précédente
25000 ce lundi là le cortège un peu
fourre-tout ne cesse de grossir d'année
plus seulement saxons allemand c'est
désormais un mouvement européen les
tueries de charlie hebdo et du
supermarché cacher à paris ne sont pas
étrangères à cette forte mobilisation
dans le cortège un drapeau français
flotte même au milieu des bannières
allemande tout on est vraiment désolé de
ce qui s'est passé en france on it
meilleur c'est exactement ce de ça dont
on a peur de ces gens importe leur
fanatisme
mais pour les contre-manifestants des
guides a fait de la récupération et des
amalgames dangereux
j'ai dessiné cette caricature pour
montrer que peggy da à instrumentaliser
les attentats parisiens qui sont
d'ailleurs terrible pour leur propre
intérêt pour alimenter leurs discours
contre les réfugiés et contre tous les
musulmans
après le passage des manifestants
islamophobes les antilles peggy dames
ont manifesté à leur tour par le même
itinéraire balai à la main c'est pour
nettoyer la ville du passage des gens de
paix guide à des contre manifestations
comme celle de dresde
il y en a eu dans toutes les grandes
villes du pays comme ici à berlin où la
chancelière angela merkel et le
président allemand ont participé à un
rassemblement contre l'islamophobie
aulas image symbolique angela merkel qui
prit aux côtés de représentants de la
communauté musulmane en allemagne
un reportage signé jeremy hartmann deux
invités nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
une députée allemande evelyne gebhardt
bonjour bonjour est membre du groupe des
socialistes européens à vos côtés et
aymeric chauprade bonjour vous êtes
député français du front national vous
avez été élu député européen mai dernier
vous siégez comme non inscrit a le front
national n'ayant pas de groupe ici au
parlement européen à leur première
question toute simple
evelyne gebhardt ce mouvement peggy da
c'est quoi si on le savait réellement ce
serait plus facile de gérer bien sûr en
allemand ce que ce qui se passe parce
qu'il l'a il ya un amalgame de de gens
qui ont des idées très différentes et
qui sont que dont les extrêmes droites
et c'est maintenant de récupérer 7 7 7
pouces et de personnes qui sont contre
les homosexuels qui sont contre les
islams ce qui sont contre la politique
en général contre la police contre tout
et ça ça fait un amalgame assez
dangereux pour la société de celui là je
suis contre je suis content
oui je suis contre je suis content
raconte quand on demande aux gens de
élida mais qu'est ce que vous voulez en
fait on a qu'une seule réponse nous
sommes contre contre quelque chose mais
des choses très différentes donc il est
assez difficile de dire ce qu'ils valent
réellement aymeric chauprade tandis que
ce mouvement peggy da pourrait faire des
émules en europe notamment en france
moi je crois que peggy d'assez
simplement l'expression populaire
spontanée d'une certaine peur de
l'islamisation de l'europe il s'agit pas
de la peur des musulmans en général
d'ailleurs j'ai entendu les différents
intervenants de ce mouvement
il s'agit de la peur de l'islamisation
au départ cela a été dit par un prof oui
mais c'est assez embêtant de dire ça
vous savez dressed c'est la ville en
allemagne qui a le plus petit nombre de
musulmans 0,5 pour cent alors parler
d'islamisation c'est un peu difficile
franchement dire alors là non c'est pas
possible oui la question n'est pas de
reste c'est la question de l'allemagne
c'est la question plus largement en
europe je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est
obligé de constater qu'il ya bien sûr
sur cette grande population musulmane en
europe
une partie qui s'est radicalisée qui est
une partie importante est solide
automatiquement article maintenant il
faut faire très attention c'est une
toute petite partie est très dangereux
ça je suis d'accord il faut lutter
contre mais on ne peut pas faire dire
les musulmans en général et c'est ça ce
qui se passe non en ce moment avec peggy
da et là je pense qu'il faut vraiment
faire très attention à ce jour différent
pas entendre en tout cas du côté de pays
d'à cette assimilation de tous les
musulmans à l'islam radical il ya bien
une distinction entre les musulmans
radicaliser vous savez que les services
occidentaux dans le monde du disque il y
à peu près 15 à 20% des 1,5 milliard de
musulmans qui sont radicalisés mais 15 à
20%
c'est de l'ordre de 300 millions je ne
sais pas d'où venaient ces chiffres là
parce qu'en allemagne où la d'autres
chiffres on parle de 2 3 à 4%
non mais je ne parle pas des djihadistes
avéré je parle de ceux qui se sont
radicalisées des tendance salafiste dre
des frères musulmans crois
qu'aujourd'hui les musulmans eux mêmes
les musulmans pacifiques qui sont très
nombreux les musulmans qui se sont
intégrés dans les sociétés européennes
veulent que l'on fasse cette distinction
parce que c'est justement ne faisant pas
cette distinction en disant que tout va
bien qu'il n'y a pas de problème avec
l'islam
façon générale qu'il s'agit de quelques
djihadistes c'est justement comme ça que
la suspicion tout et qu'on a parce que
bon la communauté musulmane en allemagne
ce sont les turcs et ce qui pose
problème en général n'ont en général
c'est ça qui est qui et le très grand
problème c'est que nous voyons tout une
partie de la société
disons que j'ai lu des statistiques
d'hier sur européenne sur la manière
dont on a présenté l'islam dans les
médias ces dernières années et tout en
particulier en allemagne et en italie
on a montré une vue négative en étant
ces terroristes dans le même bain et
c'est ça qui fait peur finalement et je
pense que dans notre société nous devons
faire beaucoup plus attention à faire
une séparation entre ceux qui sont
radicalisées que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter c'est bien clair c'est de bien
dire clairement mais les musulmans en
général ce ne sont pas ceux là et là je
pense que c'est cesser le travail à
faire dans notre société british open
briques chauprade dans une vidéo
enregistrée ici au parlement européen et
publiée sur youtube vous dit
la france est en guerre contre des
musulmans aléas de musulmans des
musulmans qu'il existe en france une
cinquième colonne qui pourrait être
dangereuse pour le pays en fait même le
parallèle avec avec les croisades
aymeric chauprade s ne me croisent en
jeu avec les croisades à la fin non je
parle du du risque du totalitarisme vous
savez je dis simplement que dans
l'histoire
est-ce que c'est sérieux comme dit si je
vous réponds et vous verrez ensuite vous
jugerez si c'est sérieux je dis
simplement que les totalitarismes se
sont formés avec une minorité au départ
il y à une minorité de musulmans qui a
un projet qui est totalitaire qui est
l'islam radical et cette minorité qui
est active
malheureusement peut convertir une
partie importante d'autres musulmans et
c'est important de faire la distinction
aujourd'hui beaucoup de pays musulmans
ou pour je pense à monsieur al sisi en
egypte avertissent de ce risque et
demandent eux mêmes d'ailleurs une
réforme de l'islam pour extirper les
racines et je crois d'ailleurs qu'à
propos de peggy da c'est très injuste de
dire qu'il s'agit d'une sorte de
naissance d'un nazisme parce que les
nazis voulaient me barman qui est à la
tête de peguy da il s'est fait montrer
comme hitler dans mois de septembre
dernier à présent il est de retour
alors ne ne me dites pas que c'est pas
totalement vous connaissez l'histoire
allemande mieux que moi
le nazisme était alliée avec l'islam
radical précisément il a d'ailleurs cédé
bien il leur lui-même avait deux objets
fétiches sur son bureau mein kampf est
le coran donc quand on dit alors là des
idioties comme ça vraiment charmant il a
réussi à résister et la mosquée de
munich qui a été une des grands un des
grands centres de prédication de l'islam
radical a été installé par reprenez vos
cours d'histoire je vous en prie alors
je crois que chacun pourra vérifier on
va calmer le débat la face à la panique
la chancelière angela merkel elle reste
droite dans ses bottes
on l'écouté on réagisse juste après
la sapn bien la discrimination et
l'exclusion ne doivent pas avoir de
place chez nous c'est pourquoi nous
poursuivons avec résolution les actes
antisémites avec tous les moyens de
l'état de droit c'est aussi valable pour
les attaques contre les mosquées
elles seront aussi poursuivi voilà lutte
contre l'antisémitisme mais aussi lutte
contre ceux qui s'attaquent aux mosquées
une chancelière ferme et légale
oui c'est très nécessaire c'est très
nécessaire parce que dans notre
constitution d'ailleurs aussi dans la
constitution européenne que nous avons
il est bien dit très clairement que les
êtres humains sont à respecter en
général et pas seulement les français ou
les allemands ou les catholiques où les
protestants ou je ne sais qui donc tous
les êtres humains ont la même valeur
dans nos sociétés et nous devons faire
en sorte que cela reste vraiment une des
bases de notre vie commune
aymeric chauprade vous pensez qu'un
peggy d'art en france c'est possible moi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le front
national incarne cette préoccupation de
l'identité de la france et de manière je
dirais national marine le pen n'était
pas d'accord avec votre de manioc d'hier
elle voulait pas que ce soit à publier
c'est marion maréchal-le pen qu'il l'a
publié elle se désolidarise un peu de
vous marine le pen elle dit que vous
êtes plus son conseiller à
l'international c'est indiqué que je
fasse est un autre sujet mais moi ce que
je dis et si vous entendez cette vidéo
je crois qu'elle est parfait je l'écouté
elle dure dure elle est parfaitement
équilibré je parle de l'islam acclimaté
aux nations qu'est l'islam majoritaire
l'islam qui s'est acclimaté qui ne pose
pas de problème mais je parle de cet
islam global djihadistes qui se
développe il faut il faut quand même pas
se voiler la face aujourd'hui on a un
problème avec une partie de l'islam et
c'est de l'intérêt non seulement dans
les colonnes des gens endormis qui
pourraient se je parle de retourner
contre le pays parle d'une minorité
active qui a pour projet politique
quelque chose qui n'est pas compatible
avec nos valeurs et nos institutions
c'est vrai de la france seulement la
manière dont vous le dites sous-entend
que cette minorité quand même une
majorité et c'est ça le problème de la
manière dont vous présentez les choses
et je pense que là nous devons faire
très attention au tour asi asi je sais
ce en sus des gens de peggy da qu'il
parlait des musulmans
generali moi j'en ai entendu j'en ai
entendu malheureusement et ça c'est
vraiment un traître on l'a vu dans le
reportage de jérémy hartmann début ils
disent wir sind das volk nous sommes là
c'était le slogan qu'on commençait
d'accéder à votre honneur
c'était le slogan qui avait été lancé
contre la r d en parler par les citoyens
et je trouve ça vraiment très pénible
d'entendre ces gens-là prendre ce slogan
où il s'agissait de lutter pour avoir la
liberté pour devenir une société ouverte
utilisé par des gens qui veulent
justement le contraire qui rend
justement le contraire ça je le trouve
très pénible société ouverte ça veut
dire quoi une société ouverte aux
hétéros regarde ce sens elle est ouverte
ça veut dire le respect des personnes
lun 15 à ce moment mâcon soudan disant
très clairement que les terroristes
on n'en veut pas c'est clair il faut
lutter contre mais on ne peut pas
sous-entendre que une partie de notre
population seulement parce qu'elle est
musulmane est presque automatiquement
vers la personne de 10 lahmada nous
disons simplement les terroristes les
terroristes puissent dans un vivier ce
vivier qui est important malheureusement
est une partie du monde musulman qui
s'est radicalisée
c'est vrai en europe c'est vrai dans le
monde arabe et c'est vrai ailleurs et
encore une fois beaucoup de musulmans de
penseurs musulmans modérés appellent
eux-mêmes à regarder le problème en face
à extirper la violence les racines de la
violence
quelque chose de positif et je vais dire
franchement et je trouve que ça a été
une très bonne chose justement à berlin
de voir toutes les religions venir
ensemble avec les mii sur invitation des
musulmans en fait que madame merkel et
d'autres ces gens du pays alors c'est
quoi ces dépôts mais des racistes des
parades et pas raciste des voix comme
vous allez dire et puis on ne peut pas
vraiment dire il ya beaucoup de raciste
il ya des antisémites
il ya des laissés pour compte il y a des
gens du milieu de la société qui sont
contre quelque chose donc c'est un
amalgame
gérard je crois que savoir quand même
beaucoup de mépris pour toute cette
population qui vit au contact des
problèmes posés par l'immigration non
contrôlée et posez vous dire que nos
adresses il ya pas beaucoup de musulmans
non il ya de l'immigration adresse
adresse fougasse 0,5 pour cent de
musulmans alors franchement parler 10
mhz d'islamisation de la population
allemande justement à dresde la ville où
il ya le moins d'étrangers d'ailleurs
peut-être vous c'est aussi ainsi on va
créer personnes me convaincre et
personne ni en france ni en allemagne
qu'il n'y a pas eu un ami attendait ont
fermé dès qu'il n'y a pas une dynamique
démographique du de l'islam en europe
occidentale cette expansion
démographique existe le problème est le
suivant il ya une partie qui
s'assimilent ça ne pose pas de problème
et une autre qui finalement vient avec
un projet qui n'est pas compatible avec
notre civilisation nos valeurs le
respect d'égalité des femmes et des
hommes le respect de la liberté de
religion le fait d'avoir le droit de
sortir de l'islam ou d'entrer dans une
religion ou inversement
tout ça fait partie de nos valeurs or il
y à une partie une partie des musulmans
qui le refusent et tant qu'on refusera
de prendre ce problème à bras le corps
je crois que ce sera un problème pour
tout le monde pour l'ensemble des
peuples européens mais aussi pour les
immigrés d'origine musulmane eux mêmes
qui ont fait cet effort d'assimilation
dans nos sociétés allemandes et
françaises
le problème des gens c'est ils disent
nous sommes dans une phase où nous
sommes le peuple
c'est une minorité et une ligne
autorités disant qu'elle est le peuple
qu'elle parle pour toute l'allemagne
c'est impensable c'est pas vrai et ça
c'est clair doit vous mettra pas
d'accord en tout cas merci à vous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation c'est
la fin d'europe hebdo merci de nous
avoir suivis rester avec nous sur les
chaînes parlementaires
/